my name is Mohit mazumdar and I am a
bioinformatician by education and since
last 12 years I've been practicing and
applying bioinformatics for research and
now both research and for collaborations
and for education so during my PhD I was
working on several drug targets and key
protein key proteins as I was associated
with a structural biology lab and uh and
that had led to several opportunities to
actually work on new structures which
are not even published and then what are
the different ways to analyze those
structures what are this how much they
are talking about about the function and
what are the different ways we can
correlate structure with function and
then probably design several strategies
around it so um as I was telling you
that uh in my PhD I was working with
several key drug targets and one of the
objectives was to understand the
site-specific mechanism so sometimes or
the objective of doing uh drug Discovery
project or structural biology project or
understanding the chemical informatics
that would be required to uh give us the
desired result it is important to
understand the um the specifics of the
very much detailed version of what you
can look at and of what you can find in
literature in different databases and
then develop a model so that's that
would be the purpose of this uh this
entire entire program so understanding
the site specific differences mechanisms
comparisons and I'm talking about
three-dimensional structures here and
then developing strategies to overcome
challenges specific to structure based
drug designing and learning about how
What would the next steps so what would
be the next steps for after the
structure based drug designing and
understanding where molecular Dynamic
simulations and quantum mechanics all of
that are applicable and where are the
innovations that are happening in the
industry with AI and the Deep learning
but to give you a prospective this is a
chem informatics in biomedical Discovery
program and we should be able to
together visualize how all of this would
be because all of this will be a visual
experience so you'll be working on
three-dimensional structures and at the
same time you'll be working and looking
at small molecules so let's start with
this slide which which shows the
emerging drugs so to understand that I
mean how the drugs actually look like
it's it's it's uh it's a slide basically
describing that that the
the fda's center for drug evaluation and
research which has approved 16 new
medicines uh for now and 50 Noble drugs
were approved in 2021 and 53 Noble drugs
were approved in 2020 so uh in 2022 the
potential new drug targets are you can
see that there are big companies
involved in this you can see you know
what is AstraZeneca and then different
types of molecules which are like more
Target based so if you can see that
astrazeneca's served for treatment of er
positive breast cancer which is more
specific to uh individual mutations are
also
also described in this in this uh
in the slide so talking about malaria
new products on on malaria or the drug
that Biogen came up with for autoimmune
diseases and then for Bristol Myers the
ubiquitinase mechanism targeting that
and like it's mutual ligates uh
modulation so these are Target driven
drugs and uh this is this is described
with a mechanism of action and we can
perhaps uh maybe understand some of
these case studies in the program going
forward that how drug purposing is also
uh drug repurposing is also
uh one of the ways we can we can counter
or we can find solutions to some of
these diseases and today in this session
we will be using one of such case
studies uh which is a straightforward
case uh that uh
that we would be looking at so thank you
for all of you for starting to share
about your background it's really
helpful to learn uh starting from
[Music]
and all of you so it says thank you so
much for sharing about your educational
background and uh where where you are
from I see that we have a lot of a lot
of students from our participants from
Nigeria and we have a lot of uh also
ongoing programs going in Nigeria and
Africa so good to see participants from
South Africa and India and I'm hoping
that we will be able to help you uh help
you with some of the structural biology
related uh queries structural biology
related uh ideas because in this program
uh the one of the objective is to
develop that idea to a project and
that's why sonalika specifically
discussed about that in the beginning
and shared also the project submission
form so please feel free to write about
your ideas maybe you don't have all the
components there but then you can
obviously connect with us on Skype and
have those discussions and we will be
able to answer them not right away but
whenever we will be able to see them we
will be able to uh able to communicate
in that sense so when you're
communicating on Skype and when you're
communicating in other places please be
patient as we are working uh all the
time but we will be looking at those
questions and we'll be helping you out
with answers and then we have these
sessions planned as well along with that
there are recorded sessions and videos
and all of this so I think we will be
able to cover all of that
uh uh okay hello matter so um Andrea and
Clement and ishaku so thank you again
and now about the context of the program
uh now we are moving towards the
um towards the actual session so in the
context of the program this is the learn
program page and uh we will be running
this program for at least three months
which is also one of the subscription
levels so to those who are subscribing
for three months or 60 days uh two
months or one and a half months 45 days
we will be able to cover and cover those
objectives within the time frame uh now
about today's session so today's session
is uh focused on uh some of the basic
concepts that are really important to
start from the beginning and develop an
understanding and holistic understanding
of how structural biology or
computational structure biology is being
utilized by researchers and utilized by
industry tree so understanding the
molecular structure of biological
macromolecules because those are the
target structures then understanding
what are the technologies that are being
used right now to generate such
information and the technology could be
about the way we have evolved using you
know extraterrestrialography now cryo em
and all of that and then what are the
ways to uh way to look at this what are
the primary secondary tertiary
quaternary structural domains structural
Motors protein subunits so many of them
are covered in basic textbooks and I
guess many of you are kind of uh aware
about all of this and perhaps anyone can
Google some of these keywords and get a
better understanding from their search
results by going through Wikipedia and
all so our Focus will not be you know to
go through the go through these topics
just like a traditional way but what we
will be doing is like we will be working
on some of these topics uh do some
Hands-On and uh understand from a case
study level but again uh we for those
who are from uh from not from a
structural biology background have never
heard of some of these keywords we have
put together these lessons that will be
helpful for those who unders wants to
understand for example what is
structural biology structural biology is
the study of how biological molecules
are built using a variety of Imaging
techniques scientists to view molecules
in three dimensions to see how they are
assembled how they function how they
interact
so that has helped researchers
understand how the thousands of
different molecules in each of our cells
work together to keep us healthy so
structural Studies have shown how uh you
know mutations or mishapans molecules
make us sick and as a result this study
have Studies have prompted immune
treatments for many diseases so that is
one of the objectives moleculars what
are molecules so molecules can be
grouped into two or three atoms set
together by a chemical bond so molecules
we will be discussing about RNA will be
discussed about DNA proteins
carbohydrates sugar and lipids fat so
structured biologist as a as structural
biologists these are very particularly
interest interest
gives a lot of interest because of the
nature of this to be protein and then we
are investigating these large molecules
made up of combination of RNA and
protein and then RNA protein complexes
so these proteins are molecules that
contribute virtually to every activity
in the body they form air they form
fingernails they carry oxygen in the
blood allow muscles to grow and move and
much more so proteins are made of long
strands of small molecules called amino
acids and we will be looking at amino
acids how they look in three dimension
uh and what are the way they move and
what are the different side chains and
all of that so uh there are 20 amino
acids found in nature each Mi each
protein contains a unique combination of
few dozens of many thousands of amino
acids so some proteins consist of
multiple amino acid strands that are
wound together
so one of the important aspects of
discussing about all of this is also uh
like the shape uh when we are discussing
about uh the shape uh we are discussing
about the three-dimensional or the
tertiary structure and we are talking
about the strand twist bands and folds
so uh then we are discussing about how
to understand uh the Whey Protein folds
so we in this context would also be
discussing about the new AI driven AI
guided deepmind Alpha fold and we'll
discuss that how protein folding has has
been almost
now much more easier than to do this
before so all of this I mean now anyone
can do this and students from high
school students without a background of
biology and specifically computational
biology will be able to learn and and go
through this training and learn how to
apply this and how to use this
so we have a couple of lessons that
describes uh the computational structure
biology that we would be covering in
this session and the next session
introduction to chem informatics where
we will be discussing about the
chemical world so
um the different aspects of proteins
like we will be discussing about these
different case studies which are about
different proteins so different proteins
have different functions and their
shapes or specific functions help cell
hold their shapes and move and movement
and all of that there is a type of
protein called transporter proteins that
are embedded in the cells outer membrane
and form channels that are that helps in
vital movement of vital substances such
as sodium calcium that pass into or out
of the cell so I mean in the context of
drug discovery
uh in the context of drug Discovery or
to develop new drugs so drugs typically
work by either blocking or supporting
the activity of specific proteins in the
body so uh we will be discussing an
approach called structure-based drug
designing
um where scientists usually make a
template for a protein use that
blueprint to create new medicines so
that's the mechanism in a Layman's word
but to do this computationally we will
be able to do this in an instantly
environment where the the thought
process will be to mimic what is
happening within the body or within the
system so computer model would allow
that allows us like to examine this in
several ways and that's why we were
talking about you know molecular dynamic
simulations or we are talking about
molecular docking simulations so
um I mean there are several examples now
where people have determine this or have
gone into different clinical stages and
also come up with a drug structure based
drug and now knowledge based as well so
there's a lot of information and there
is so much databases and now what we've
been able to do is connect that
information uh fill up those uh connect
those dots fill up those blanks and that
utilizes you know deep learning a lot of
deep learning and a lot of structure
based or knowledge based drug Discovery
so all of this could be learned through
the coursework that we've been
discussing this is a short session so
one of the objective would be to for you
would be to understand this in the
context that where are these resources
and what we can do when before we meet
again so these are some of the things
that you can do on your own and together
with the help of mentors we will be able
to on some of these aspects now
the first thing we need to do to start
going to get going is to understand that
where is this data is available and how
to interpret this data so today we will
be doing that so protein Data Bank
archive information about CD structures
of proteins nucleic acids and protein
Data Bank is a free repository where we
would be going and doing some for
analysis understanding where to find
this information how to interpret this
information so I was talking about the
three dimensional shapes but in terms of
proteins you can see here in this image
different types of proteins and like
really all kind of weird shapes and uh
like really I mean that kind of explains
the diversity in this in this area so
I'm me now what we want to know about
this how complex assemblies and this
understanding help students and
researchers understand all aspects of
biomedicine and we will know about
application in biomedicine which is
quite evident but it has application in
agriculture uh from protein synthesis to
health and diseases so the rcsb pdb
uh builds upon the data
by creating tools and resources for
research and education as well education
in molecular biology structured biology
computational biology and Beyond and one
of the things that we will be discussing
in this context is about a case study
that would be on SARS proof too uh with
19 so in one and a half year of the
world world health organizations
declaration within one and a half year
when uh like when who
declared that copyright 19 is a pandemic
over 1000 structures of SARS move to
biomolecules have been deposited in the
protein Data Bank it's a rare to obtain
such a it's very rare to obtain such a
snapshot of intense effort and
structural biology and that happened and
still there are so many structures
coming up especially with cryohe am now
and and then there are other
repositories so here in the image you're
seeing protein Data Bank you're seeing
uh other repositories which are
maintained by EMB and ebi
so
um in that context it's on it's
important to understand where to find
the information where to find these sort
of information which is already
available which can actually help you
save a lot of days in your research it
will actually help you explain this to
someone else in a in a very simplified
way so that you can go to the next level
so that's why that's the objective of
the session and unibrot for example uh
if you just search in uni product uh is
is one of the world's leading high
quality comprehensive and freely
resource of freely accessible resource
of protein sequences and functional
information so similarly after these are
the data databases and repositories
which are maintained by which are
maintained by embl Epi so we will be
looking at the Repository trees that are
maintained by ncbi
in the ncbi portal as well but in
today's session we will be looking at
some of these repositories so uh about
pdb uh e is again the founding member of
of the worldwide ww protein Data Bank
wwpdp which collects and organize and
decimates this data for
biological micro molecular structures so
there's a lot of information or
structures that could be downloaded from
here and understand the the chemistry
some of the chemistry how it is
connected with it so embl has also
developed and integrated with Alpha fold
so Alpha fold is a AI system developed
by deepmind and that predicts proteins
3D structure from its amino acid
sequence it regularly achieves accuracy
competitive with the experimental
structure so I have been you know uh
talking about this Alpha fold and in
many of my webinars we have gone through
the way Alpha code came up and uh also
we have gone through
um one of the video uh which explains
Alpha 4. so just let me ask you this
question like how many of you know about
Alpha Sport and are you interested to
look at the video of how this came up or
uh we would you want to skip that part
so can you tell me in the chat please so
do you know about how much you know
about Alpha 4 you're interested in the
video or let's skip that so as I was
telling you that Alpha full is the AI
system developed by deepmind and it
predicts protein structures three
structures from sequences so deep mind
uh uh deepmind and embl uh European
biomedic bioinformatics Institute ebi
has partnered to create an alpha 4
database so the alpha full database uh
which is what I'm showing you on the
slide is to make this predictions freely
available to the scientific community
so and since it has been an year that in
the cast 14 they did this and then uh it
has been a year so since then they have
done a true they have done 200 200
million predictions so they have done
200 million predictions which is
available on this website that is what
I'm showing you on the screen and uh we
will be sharing the links
told you about that but after this after
the session there will be an email that
will that will have all this information
that we are covering and then you will
also get the video recording so that's
another way
so right so as I was saying that the
latest uh alpha alpha this database
contains 200 million protein structures
and provide a broad coverage of unibrow
uh where you will be able to see protein
sequences as well as the notation so
it's a great place to you know to work
it's a great place to come up with
research proposals and problems and
finding those proposals and problems so
uh you can individually download that in
the context of human proteome and uh 47
other key organisms so you can Target
organism wise look at the structures
predicted structures and then
hypothesize from there so it's it's it's
very becoming much and much easier it's
just that one one has to look at it and
and then start digging and then develop
a proposal uh that's what I will be
expecting from some of you uh before we
meet again so please I mean go through
these resources and uh then look at some
of the uh some of the interest
interested protein structures interested
proteins or interested organisms that
you would want to go further investigate
further and then we would be able to uh
we would be able to do this so let's
move to the next video I think you said
that you are interested in the video so
in the next session when we have the
alpha fold also planned so these are
some of the links GitHub links Google
collab notebooks that we will be going
through so today's session we are not
doing Google collab but we will be
having a Basics basic introduction to
Google collab and then we will run some
of the collab notebooks and run some
predictions uh using python Google
collab